in 1969 in July three Americans launched
into space now they went to the surface
the moon they famously made the great
leap for mankind Buzz Aldrin Neil
Armstrong he walked on the surface they
planted this flag it's rightly
celebrated as in a moment that in
America we say is a triumph right we
think it was this amazing accomplishment
they didn't just leave behind this flag
though they also left behind a plaque
now this plaque is a beautiful object
and one that I want to talk to you a
little bit about first you might notice
that there's two globes
representing all of Earth and then
there's this beautiful statement right
we came in peace for all mankind now at
first this is just nice poetic language
but it's also set in a typeface it is
perfect for this moment now it seems
industrial it seems engineered it also
is the best possible name you could come
up with for something on the moon Futura
now I want to talk to you about fonts
and why this typeface is perfect for
this moment but it's actually more than
just ceremonial now when all of you
arrived here today you actually had to
think about fonts now you might not
realize if you're all unconscious
experts on typography now typography is
the study of how fonts inhabit our world
they're the visual language of words we
use now here's the thing that's funny
about this though I know you're probably
not like me you're not a font nerd maybe
some of you are but if you're not that's
alright because you know I might spend
hours upon every day trying to pick the
perfect typeface for the perfect project
or I might spend thousands of dollars
every year trying to get ones with the
right features but all of you actually
spent hours every day evaluating fonts
now if you don't believe me think about
how you got here
each of you had to judge by the signs
and maybe even on your phone which
things which signals to trust in which
to ignore you were evaluating fonts or
maybe when you're just buying a new
product you have to think about whether
something is expensive or cheap or hard
to get or easy to find and the funny
thing
about is the you know this may not seem
extraordinary - but the moment you see
something out of place you recognize it
right away
now the thing I love about typography
and why I love fonts and why I love
Futura is that for me what I study is
everywhere every street that I walk down
every book that I pick up every move
every thing that I read is filled with
the thing I love now once you understand
this the history and what happens with
typography you actually have it on a
history of everything before you and
this is the typeface future as as
previous even discussed this is
modernism and miniature this is a way in
which modernism infiltrated this country
and became perhaps the most popular or a
promiscuous typeface of the 20th century
less is more right these are the RISM of
modernism and in the visual arts the
same thing happened let's focus on the
essentials focus on the basic shapes
focus on geometry so future actually
holds this to its core you might notice
that the shapes inherent in future I
have circles squares triangles some of
the shapes are all based on circles like
the ODN sea or others have this pointed
apex of the triangle or others just look
like they might have been made with a
ruler or a compass they feel geometric
they feel mathematic they feel precise
and in fact this whole system carries
through with the way that the typeface
was designed to not look like it was
made like other typefaces to be
something new right here it is in the
lightweight the medium weight and the
bold weight in fact the whole family has
different things to come into it this
was a conscious break from the past
something that was looked like he was
made by a machine and not by hand and
when I say not made my hand this is what
I mean this is what we think about maybe
when when you might create something
with a calligraphic brush or a pen that
there's thick's and Thins and even more
traditional typefaces say like a
Garamond holds messages of this old
system in which you can see that the the
a where it gets a little bit thinner at
the top and then thicker down below
because it's trying to look like someone
who made it by hand but Futura in
contrast is designed to look like no one
had touched it at all that this was made
by a machine for a machine age for an
industrial age now there's actually a
sleight of hand here that Paul Renard
the designer who made this in 1927
employed if you look at the way in which
the circular shape join
with the vertical shaft you'll notice
that it tapers just ever so slightly and
this is one of hundreds of ways in which
this typeface was designed to look
geometrically perfect even though it's
mathematically not and this is what
typeface designers do all the time to
make typefaces work every day now there
was other designers doing this at the
same time in Europe and in America these
are a few other excellent examples from
Europe trying to create something new
for a new age for a new moment in time
in fact these are some other ones in
Germany that in some ways look very
similar to futuro maybe with higher
waist or lower waist or different
proportions then why future why did
Futura take over the world well in this
case if you can read the the titles
there some of these names don't quite
wear off the tongue herb our cable light
Berthold grotesque elegant grotesque
these aren't exactly household names are
they and so when you compare that to
Futura
you realize that this was a really good
choice by the marketing team what's
amazing about this name what do you
think we know what's in this name is
that this is a name that actually
invokes hope and an idea about the
future and this isn't actually the word
for a future in German it wasn't a
German name they actually picked
something that would speak to a wider
larger audience a universal audience and
when you compare it to what was being
done in America these are these are
typefaces from the same period in the
United States in the 1920s bold brash
braggadocious you almost think of this
is exactly like what the stock market
looked like when they were all going
nuts in the 1920s right and this you
realize that future is doing something
actually revolutionary now I wanted to
step back and talk about a example of
the typeface in use so this is a
magazine that we all probably know today
at Vanity Fair this is what it looked
like in in 1929 in the summer and in
many ways there's nothing wrong with
this design this is absolutely typical
of the 1920s there's a photograph of an
important person in this case franklin
roosevelt then governor of new york
everything seems centered everything
seems symmetrical there's still a little
bit of ornamentation so this is still
may be having some vestiges of the
painted lady and not fully modernistic
but everything seems kind of solid
there's even dropped caps to help you
get into the text but guess what this
all changed very quickly in October of
1929 a Berlin based designer came and
redesigned a fan atif air and this is
what it looks like with Futura instead
of the governor
we have a photograph of an abstract
beautiful setting in this case the ocean
instead of drop caps there's nothing at
all and replaced with a centered layout
is now a symmetry and it gets even more
radical the further you are into the
magazine in this case even more dramatic
asymmetry in this case illustrations by
Pablo Picasso moving across the page and
breaking the the the gutter of the the
two pages and there's something even
more radical if you look closely at the
future you might notice something now
you might not pick it up at first but
there are no capital letters in the
title or the captions on this page now
you might not think that's very radical
but pick up any magazine any book or go
to any website and I guarantee you are
not going to find it very easily this is
still a radical idea and why is that
radical well when we think about what
capital letters denote they denote
something that's important right whether
it's our names or our titles or maybe
even just the name of our corporations
or maybe our trademarks actually in some
ways America is the the home of
capitalization we love putting capitals
and everything but think about how
radical this would be to and introduce a
magazine where you were taking away all
the capital letters this is maybe have
the same political force that we now
argue over things like pronouns in our
society today in the 1920s this is just
shortly after Soviet Russia had had a
communist revolution and for them this
actually represented a socialist
infiltration into America all lowercase
letters meant that this was an
egalitarian complete lowering of
everything into one equal playing field
now this is still kind of a radical idea
think about how often you do capitalize
something to have more power of prestige
to it
so for them to do this was a way in
which Futura was using this idea now
other designers were doing other things
with future others brought other ideas
of modernism with it whether it was
interesting new illustration styles or
interesting new collage types of
illustration or even just do book covers
whether they were from Europe but here's
the funny thing
in the 1920s if you wanted to use a new
typeface you couldn't just go download
onto your computer you actually had to
have pieces of lead so for Americans we
wanted to adopt this and make it part of
their own
system something they could use in
everyday typography whether in ads or
anything else they actually had to have
metal type so being good American
capitalist what did we do we made all
sorts of copies ones that had nothing to
do with the name Futura but looked
identical to it whether it was Spartan
or tempo and in fact by the time that
World War two started
American corporations were actually
trying to boycott Nazi goods but they
said go ahead and use our copies right
use twentieth-century use Spartan use
vogue use tempo these are all identical
to Futura and in fact for most people
they didn't even learn the new names
they just still called it all Futura
so America took this typeface in
conquered it and made it its own so by
the time World War two finishes
Americans are using this on everything
whether it be catalogs or atlases or
encyclopedias or charts and graphs or
calendars or even political material and
even the logo for the for a new
expansion football team and in fact it
was used even on some of the most
important advertising of the 20th
century so it's in this context that
when the US government was picking a
typeface to use after World War two four
new maps and new projects they picked
future it wasn't an astounding choice it
wasn't a radical choice it wasn't had it
didn't have anything to do with
communism but in this case it was used
on some of the most important maps so
this one an Air Force map in 1962 or
used for the maps in Vietnam and in 66
and so it wasn't a surprise that when
astronauts were starting the mercury
program such as John Glenn orbiting the
Earth that charts and maps that he was
using were in future and in fact by the
time Mercury morphed into Apollo it
started getting used more and more for
more things so this in this case for a
safety plan or even starting to get used
on instrument panels or navigational
aids or even on diagrams to show how the
whole system worked but here's the
amazing thing it didn't just get used
for papers that they hand it out to
people it started to get used for an
interface for an entire system that
helped the astronauts know how to use
the machine NASA wasn't just one big
corporation making everything there was
hundreds of contractors Boeing IBM
McDonnell Douglas all making different
machines now imagine if astronauts had
to use different
faces in different systems for each
component they had in the app and the
space shuttle's this would have been
impossible to navigate and there had
been a cognitive overload every time
they had to open up a new system so in
this case Futura
being used on the interface helped them
navigate complexity and make it more
clear and it wasn't just used on buttons
it was used on labels and it was used on
their food rations and it was used on
their toolkits it was used on knobs and
and levers to tell them what to do in
fact maybe even some of the places where
they needed to have things that were
complex be more simple to them
instructions are printed entirely in
Futura so that they could know what to
do at that one moment they didn't have
to remember everything in their head
they could have it out there in the
world to see and refer to so in this
case future I helped make that system
which was already a very difficult and
complex system a little less complex in
fact the very first or last thing an
astronaut might have seen when they were
entering or exiting the spacecraft would
have been in Futura now one of my
favorite examples of how future worked
in this way is actually this camera this
is a Hasselblad that was made by the
swedish company it's a perfectly good
camera some of you might have used one
it's a is prized by photographers as a
really great camera and you might notice
if you know anything about cameras that
there's some modifications made to it in
this case there are stickers placed all
over in the film canisters or other
parts of the camera here now what this
enabled it NASA to do was make something
really great out of the astronauts
they're not photographers they're not
experts in art but they could ensure
that they would know how to use this
camera because of the labels placed
therein Futura so in this case future
acquired and made sure that they had
legitimacy with the things you were
using in this case to not take off the
the film before they would expose which
in this case we would have never had
some of the amazing photos we had
without this label now so when we see
something as decorative as this you know
a ceremonial patch or something like
this plate plaque on the moon we
realized that Futura was more than just
something ceremonial something more than
something that had just been picked for
its design
in fact Futura had Authority had
legitimacy and had power because of
this choice now there's one other thing
I want to talk about just in closing and
that is that future tells a story and
this is what I love about typefaces is
that all of them tell stories and in
this case this typeface tells a very
powerful story about assimilation about
something being taken into America and
being made part of its culture and
that's one of the best and worst things
America does is we take things into our
culture and we spit them out back again
and claim them our own and in this case
future a mirror is exactly what happened
with the technology undergirding the
whole system Futura was a German
typeface taken and made into an American
commodity and so were the technologies
the rockets the scientists all came from
Germany as well so in some ways this
German typeface on an American plaque
perfectly mirrors what happened with the
technology and in this case when you
think about this story you realize that
typography on the moon represents
legitimacy represents Authority and in
this case gave them the astronauts the
power to get to the moon thank you
[Applause]
[Music]